Let's get started. Welcome to the
parents who have made it today.
Thank you for sending us your bright
people to do a pay our salaries and learn
from us. Uh, as, uh, the,
we've spent most of the semester so
far figuring out what bonds is and,
and how quantum mechanics works and so on.
But now we're trying to find out how it
really happened, how people discovered,
how chemistry in general and organic
chemistry in particular work than we
started with [inaudible].
And now we're in the next generation,
which is salient in Sweden.
And as we said last time,
he was important for analysis.
He got good atomic
weights for 50 elements.
We'll talk today about a
electrolysis and dualism. Uh,
he was important for his teaching and
writing for the first half of the 19th
century.
He was the main man and in chemistry
and his notation for composition that we
talked about last time that we still use.
Okay,
so now we're going to talk about atomic
weights and equivalents and what was
involved there. We started this last
time. Remember showed how gay lose sock.
I had an alternative to, uh, to
Dalton. There was this question about,
uh, what, even if you knew, uh,
the proper ratios of elements,
what you didn't know was the ratios of
the atoms that were in them because you
didn't know whether an atomic
weight should be doubled or halved.
So they had the question about silicon
chloride was at sic sic l two S I sic l
three, s I c l four. So how could you
possibly settle something like this?
Uh, Dalton did it by assuming that
if you had only one common hat,
one compound, it had to be one to
one. Gay Lusaka went with the map,
the volumes of the gases
that were involved,
which turned out ultimately to be correct.
Although it wasn't really widely
accepted for about 60 years.
But there was another neat way of
doing it depending on crystals. Uh,
mid Salish and Austrian,
uh,
had this device on which you mount a
crystal and reflect light off it through a
telescope.
So when you do that,
you know precisely if it comes right
up the middle of the telescope,
you know exactly what direction
the, um, the plane of the surf,
that surface of the crystal is.
So what you can do then is rotate it by
a certain number of degrees until some
other face of the crystal
reflects precisely,
and then you can measure very,
very accurately what the angle
between those two faces is.
So that was crystallography in
those days before x-ray. Okay.
So here's his paper on relating
crystal shape to chemical proportions.
There was sound like not
closely related phenomena,
but here he's talking about arsenates
and phosphates and here are the pictures
he drew. They drew a beautiful
pictures of crystals in those days.
If that's all you can do, you'll
do it right? Uh, so he has an art.
Betty saw that the crystals were the same
shape for corresponding arsenates and
phosphates. This diammonium by arson
aid and the diammonium by phosphate,
right?
So he measured the angles and here's his
table at the angles corresponding and
you can see they're very,
very close to one another.
Those are the differences
in tenths of degrees.
So these crystals are precisely the same.
Now what can you conclude from that?
Anybody got an idea where
you can go from here?
So you know that there's an arsenite
and the phosphate with the same chemical
composition,
right?
And they give exactly the same shape.
So the thing that's things that packed
together must be exactly the same.
So they must have the corresponding know,
however many arsenates there are
arsenic Adams, there are in one,
there must be exactly the same number
of phosphorous atoms in the other.
Otherwise they could not possibly
be exactly the same shape.
So now you know something that we,
there was this need for relative
atomic weights. Was Dalton, right?
Was Water Aho or was Gailey's sock right?
That it was h two o right?
At least in this case,
this thing called ISO morphism,
the same shape of the crystals provided
definitive atomic weight ratios for at
least some of the Adam pairs.
So arsenic,
Adam's must play exactly the same role
in arsenates that phosphorous atoms play
in phosphates. And therefore, if you
have a hundred grams of nitrogen,
oxygen and hydrogen that combines to give
these these salts with 30.64 grams of
phosphorous or 78.11 grams of arsenic,
it must be that our snake Adam is 2.55
times as heavy as the phosphorous atom,
right?
That is,
it can't be half that or twice that.
It has to be exactly that because they
have to be the same number to give
exactly the same shape. Okay, so there
was one way of determining this ratio,
but it wasn't trivial.
Okay?
Now here's presale is his
table of atomic and Mike,
your weights from the or 1831 and
if we zoom in on it a bit here,
you can see he gave two
columns for the atomic weights,
one based on oxygen being 100 units and
the other based on h with a bar across
it being one. Now the bar across Adam's
means that the atoms are doubled.
You can have it without a bar,
which is a single atom or the bar across.
That means it's a doubled them.
So he had actually noticed,
if you go down the column there
that if you assume h two is one,
then obviously h here is a half,
right?
So these were the numbers he had in
1831 and we could compare them with what
they would be nowadays if you scaled
to oxygen as we defined it now to be 15
point 900900900 four and then you see
that they're off by about 1% up or down.
How does that compare with
what Dalton was getting?
Do you remember how accurate he was?
He was about 10.
So here in, in uh, 25 years,
they've gotten 10 fold more accurate
in what the atomic weights are. Okay.
Uh, now combustion analysis was, was, was,
and would continue to be from the time
of Avazi a white through the whole 19th
century,
the heavy carrier for organic chemistry.
Okay, here's the way, but
salients did combustion analysis.
So he started with a tube in which he
put a half a gram of organic substance
that was going to be analyzed, three
grams of sodium chlorate you remember?
That's what gay Lusaka used to burn
things with. Why that rather than air,
why did Gail Lusaka use it
rather than air? Do you remember?
Cause a lot of things wouldn't burn
in air. Right. They would char. Okay.
So,
but he used this,
they use Galeas socks oxidizing agent and
50 grams of sodium chloride was ground
up with this stuff just so that,
uh,
the reaction wouldn't get out of
hand so it wouldn't explode. Okay.
So those are put in there.
Then he heated up the neck and drew it
out and plugged it in to that bulb on the
right. Right. So he joined
it to that bulb, which would
serve for collecting water,
which is a combustion product and
a calcium chloride drying tube,
which would get the,
which would get the rest of the water
that didn't condense and the bulb. Okay.
Then he assembled this thing along the
bottom so that the gasses that came out
after the water was removed what exit in
and be collected in this bell jar over
mercury.
And in that there was a bulb that floated,
which held potassium hydroxide,
solid potassium hydroxide,
which would absorb the co two,
thereby separating it from the
oxygen that would come through.
You get oxygen just by
heating sodium chlorate. Okay.
And then he closed the top with
a piece of, of glove leather.
So the mercury that was
floating on couldn't,
little drops of mercury wouldn't get
in because as you know from hefting it,
that would change the way to good deal.
Okay.
So what he did was build a fire
and move that barrier back.
So with heat from one end to the other
and the gases would come out and bubble
up in the bell jar. Right. And, and
fill up a good deal of the bell jar.
Right. Uh, and notice that the,
that the tube had been wrapped with
metal to keep it from popping when it got
hot in the fire because there'd be
pressure inside in order to bubble through
the mercury. Uh, okay.
So then the cools it off the
gas contracts, right? The,
the Koh absorbs co two. So you're
left with oxygen in the bell jar.
And the, and the CEO two is
absorbed on the potassium hydroxide,
but he then after the mercury rises,
as the gas gets absorbed,
but after the mercury stops rise,
he waits 12 hours to make sure he's got
all the co two absorbed because it has
to get through the glove leather. Right.
So it takes quite a while. It took a,
you know, much more than the day
to do it to do an analysis. Uh,
so after it stops rising,
he takes it apart.
It takes the glove leather off the top
ways that and finds out how much co two
there was.
So he's got the water and the CO2,
therefore the hydrogen and the carbon and
this was a much better way of doing it.
Then, uh, then Lavoie CA's
which required, you know,
three or four people operating
in that big machine. Okay.
Electricity was another really
important contribution from butts alias.
Okay. Uh, to, to, uh,
but it also was a contribution to
the royal institution in London, uh,
where this is a demonstration of a,
of a n two o at the Royal Institution,
but the guy holding the bellows there is,
uh,
is Humphry Davy who became the head of
the Royal Institution and was the head
then a big science. So
in 18, seven and eight,
he made some very important experiments.
It was based on the work of Volta who
was just a little more than a decade
earlier, who had invented this
thing shown on his desk here,
which was the voltaic pile,
which was a pile of copper and zinc,
uh, disks. And when you put
copper and zinc together,
you can get 1.1 volts out of it.
Okay.
So this was going to be big science.
So he put together 24 such pairs
of things, which, which uh,
which meant you could get 26 volts.
Those were six inches square. Right?
Then he made another, there's the battery
incidentally, that Butts alias had,
which is instill in Stockholm.
Okay.
Then he put one with a hundred such
things. So he could get 110 volts.
Then he made another one.
They were only four inches
square now of 165 volts. Right?
And then he could hook them together in
series so he could get 301 volts across
this thing. And then he tried
doing experiments with it.
So this is what he said.
I acted upon aqueous solutions of potash
and soda. You know what potash is?
Potassium hydroxide and soda.
Soda is sodium hydroxide saturated
that common temperatures by the highest
electrical power I could command and
which was produced by a combination of
Voltaic batteries belonging to the Royal
Institution containing 24 plates of
copper and zinc, 12 inches
square, a hundred plates,
six inches and 100 and 554 inches square.
So this is that battery,
as I just said, put 300 and whatever
number of volts across this thing.
Though there was a high
intensity of action.
The water of the solution alone was
affected in hydrogen and oxygen,
disengaged with the production of
much heat and violent effervescence.
I could believe that. And so,
so he wasn't about to give up.
He tried it again,
the presence of water appearing.
Thus to prevent any decomposition.
I used potash,
so potassium in igneous fusions.
So he put a flame to it and melted it by
means of a stream of oxygen gas from a
gas almond or applied to the flame of
a spirit lamp which was thrown onto a
platinum spoon containing potash.
This alkali was kept for some minutes
in a strong red heat and in a state of
perfect fluidity,
the spoon was preserved in communication
with the positive side of the battery.
I don't know how he held this thing,
uh,
of the power of 106 inches highly charged.
And the connection from the negative
side was made by a platinum wire by this
arrangement.
Some brilliant phenomenol were produced.
The potash appear to conduct her
in a high degree and as long as the
communication was preserved
to most intense light was
exhibited at the negative
wire and a column of flame,
which seemed to be open to the development
of combustible matter arose from the
point of contact. Right? Then
he did another experiment,
a small piece of pure potash had
been exposed for a few seconds to the
atmosphere.
So as to give a conducting power to the
surface was placed upon an insulated
disc of [inaudible],
connected with the negative side of the
battery of the power of 250 of 604 in a
state of intense activity and a platinum
wire communicating with the positive
side was brought in contact with
the upper surface of the Alkali,
small globules having a high metallic
luster and being precisely similar
invisible characters to quicksilver.
What's quicksilver?
Live silver, right?
Mercury of course. Okay.
Some of which burnt with explosion and
bright flame as soon as they were formed
and others remained and we're merely
tarnished and finally covered with a white
film which formed on their
surfaces. What was this right?
He electrolyzed uh,
he says potash,
potassium hydroxide. What
did he get? Potassium metal.
So He'd discovered a new element and
from soda he got sodium from potash,
potash. She got potassium. Okay.
Now this was a great
triumph for English science,
but those were the
period of great rivalry.
18 seven and eight the peninsular
war was going on in Portugal,
Spain against the French in
particular against Napoleon.
Napoleon had studied science a certain
amount as a student at the AA call,
Amelie tear in Paris. In fact,
he had been examined by Laplas,
the Lavoie,
CA's a colleague and measuring heat.
So, uh, he wasn't about to
knuckle under to England in this,
so he got his crew together,
including Gailey's sock and said,
why haven't we discovered this?
And Galia [inaudible] said,
we don't have the battery. He
says, you've got your battery.
So this was the battery. They that
Galeas sat constructed at garden.
So it consisted of 601 kilogram copper
plates and 603 kilograms zinc plates.
So he had 2.6 tons of metal and
in in six different troughs here.
And then he hooked them
together in series.
Alright,
so he's now got 650 volts.
Now the Napoleon was
interested in science,
so he came to visit the lab one day
and there's an account of this in the,
in the biography of Sam,
of Humphry Davy with that rapidity,
which characterized all his motions.
And before the attendance could
enter pose any precaution,
he thrust the extreme wires to the
battery under his tongue and received a
shock,
which nearly deprived him of sensation
after recovering from its effects,
he quitted the laboratory without making
any remark and was never afterwards
heard to refer to the subject.
Okay,
so that was the end of the French
competition with Humphry Davy.
But Davey himself built one with a
thousand plates with so 2,200 volts.
And with this,
he was able to prepare a bunch of elements
in addition to sodium and potassium,
Boron, magnesium, calcium, and barium
were all due to Sir Humphry Davy.
But that wasn't really the most
important thing for chemistry.
W supplied more than new elements.
It's supplied an idea.
And the idea was the organizing
principle for what was called dualism.
And dualism was the idea that there were
things that were positive and things
that were negative and they would
be attracted to one another.
Not only would they be attracted one
another, but they could trade partners.
Okay.
So remember we saw last time that the,
that the alchemists already
had vitriolic and Kukri or,
or copper sulfate. So here we
saw last time was copper sulfate.
Let me see if I can get
this thing going here.
Oh,
here.
Is it? Half tomorrow. There we go.
So there's copper sulfate
and nice and blue.
But let me get the light behind.
That should be good. Okay,
so we'll put some in here.
So this is copper as a,
as a positive stuff and
sulfate is negative stuff.
And now we'll take sodium hydroxide.
So,
and put a little bit in.
So there's a precipitate and actually
it's much more complicated than people
thought it was in those days.
It gets quite dark blue if you
put a lot of a lot in there.
But now a white whitish
precipitates going to form,
but you don't see very well here. Maybe
it doesn't know how to focus on that.
Uh, let's see. I can get
something for it to focus on
there. There you see the
precipitate. Okay, so obviously
something happened, right?
And according to dualism,
this is what happened, right?
You Mix it with caustic
soda and you have ab and CD,
positive and negative on the left,
sodium hydroxide, copper sulfate,
and they change partners and you
get a precipitate. So you have,
it's explained by electricity.
And this is then is what dualism was.
Uh, so we've noticed that
this is our family tree.
You remember? And now we've
looked at a elemental analysis,
Adams and dualism.
Notice that people are entered into this,
not by when they made their contribution
because they made it at many different
times, but by when they were born. So
you can see what the generations were.
So first we had lavoie ca then presale,
he is,
and now we're into a new generation of
people who are going to contribute when
they get to be 20 to
30 years old down here.
So the next thing we're going to talk
about is urea and isomers and the benzoyl
radical and the theory of
substitutions and types. Okay.
And our players are John Baptiste onto,
they do ma in France and
Leiby and volar in Germany.
And they were all born right around 1800.
Between 1,818 three okay.
And here they are on the, on
the, uh, outside of the building.
So we're going to look
at villa and liebig. Now,
here's the volar writing
to Brett's alias in Sweden.
He's going to be the next generation,
uh,
saying having developed the greatest
respect for you through studying your
writings.
I've always thought it would
be my greatest good fortune
to be able to practice
this science under the
direction of such a man,
which has always been my fondest desire.
Those who have seen such
letters will recognize these as,
as consistent up to the present
day. Uh, he said, he goes on to say,
although I earlier had
planned to become a physician,
and at the end he says with the greatest
respect treed Richville Villar from
Frankfurt on mine.
He was a great guy.
They carried on correspondence their
whole lives. It's really entertaining.
And because partly because Voler had sort
of a lame mish sense of humor and was
a cartoonist. So, for example,
in this letter to put Sally's
in 1837 so this is, uh,
10 years later, he said to see
this old friend palm stet again,
especially here in Gooding
and was a real delight.
He was just the same old guy with the
sole exception that he no longer wears the
little toupee swept up over
his forehead as he used to do.
So Villar drew this cartoon in there.
Okay.
But what do you know what you
know volar for probably is urea.
How many people have heard
about villa and urea? Okay.
But the interesting thing is that the
urea was not the main contribution.
He also invented the aluminum
incidentally are discovered aluminum,
but urea wasn't really
the main for our purposes,
wasn't the main contribution
from this, uh, work of, of volar.
And you'll see that there are a couple
of problems for next Wednesday and
readings on the web that support
this with original documents.
So he wrote in 1828 to produce alias.
Perhaps.
You still remember the experiment I
carried out in that fortunate time when I
was working with you in which I found
that whenever one tries to react cyanic
acid with ammonia,
a crystalline substance appears,
which is a nerd behaving neither
like CYA eight nor like ammonia.
So that,
that's what was funny,
that it didn't behave like you
would expect for ammonium cyanide.
So the idea was it should be a
double decomposition reaction.
This dualistic thing
where you change partners.
So you start with ammonium chloride,
silver Saya and eight.
That was another way he
did it and he and he,
you should get ammonium signed eight and
silver chloride was as a precipitate.
So then you can,
you've prepared ammonium signing,
but you can test whether ammonium signed.
Eight is the salt ammonium signed,
eight one is to see whether it has the
ammonium ion in it and that you can tell
by pulling the proton, often changing it
back into ammonia, which you can smell.
Okay. But when he treated it with
sodium hydroxide, he didn't get ammonia.
Okay. Or you can test. So it doesn't
behave like an ammonium salt,
nor did it behave like a, like a
cyanide salt. If you treat it with acid,
you don't get the smell
of science cyanic acid.
And if you treat it with LEDs,
you don't get led sign and eight.
So it appears not to be either
ammonia or the cyanic acid anymore.
Okay.
But what it did do when treated with
nitric acid was to give brilliant crystal
flakes.
So the crystals were what allowed him to
identify it and he knew that you've got
the same thing when you
treated urea with nitric acid,
just like those from urea and nitric acid.
Right.
So this raised the question for its alias,
wrote to Villar in reply to that,
it is a unique situation that the
assault nature so entirely disappears.
It doesn't look like dualism anymore
when the acid of the ammonia combined one
that will certainly be most
enlightening for future theory.
So might Imodium, Cya,
Nate actually be urea,
might urea ammonium Cya.
Nate with very curious properties.
So vola wrote back to personalities.
I recently performed a small experiment
appropriate to the limited time I have
available. He was doing a
lot of teaching at this time,
which I quickly completed in which thank
God, did not require a single analysis.
That was what was a pain in
the neck to do. So this was,
this is the data from,
from uh,
Villers letter and the same thing
was published his paper in 1828.
So it turned out that doctor proud to
physician in London had already analyzed
urea and reported its composition
in terms of nitrogen, carbon,
hydrogen, and oxygen. That
is its ultimate analysis.
And volar without doing an experiment,
knew what the analysis should be
for ammonium sayand aid, right?
Because he had births,
aliases, atomic weights,
so he could calculate for a substance of
that formula what the percent by weight
should be. And they agreed.
You can see very, very well.
So it looked like urea
and ammonium signed.
It had the same analysis and
therefore where the same thing,
okay, the discrepancies were
less than 2%. Remember the,
the atomic weights are only
good to about 1% okay. So the,
therefore these things appear
to be identical. In fact,
it's interesting to compare them with
the modern values, which you see here.
What do you notice in the first row?
Okay,
when you compare the numbers
in the first row, Russell?
Yeah.
What's the same?
Which is better experiment or theory?
What?
No, no. The first, the first is
Prouts analysis. The first column,
the last column is Brett's
alias volar theory.
And the middle is what we think is correct
because it's based on what we have.
Now what do you say? Aha. So there
is a good lesson for us, right?
Experiment is better than theory,
but if you look more closely,
there's a much more interesting story
here. So the moral is don't dry lab,
don't be like Lavoie Oza and try to
make your experiments conform to theory.
Right?
So because of that dot,
Dr Prout has gotten a reputation among
historians of science as a paragon of
accuracy and honesty. The very
model for x lab work. Right?
Okay. But let's look more
carefully. You notice, for example,
that he didn't make these things
add up to a hundred percent.
Would you expect them to?
What would love,
what would happen if it had been Lavoie
Xia doing it? What would they add it to?
100% exactly here at this.
And why not?
Because he's being honest. Maybe. Okay.
So notice incidentally that the theory
didn't add up to a hundred percent.
Now how do you get those numbers?
How would volar have gotten those numbers?
He decided how many atoms of
nitrogen, hydrogen, oxygen,
there are in the compound.
He'd see according to the atomic weights,
how much each of those would
way he'd add them all together.
That would be the total.
And then he'd divide each one by the
total to get how many percent it was.
Is that clear to everyone
how you do about it?
So how do you do that and not get
it to add to a hundred percent?
Well, I recalculate it using Burt's
alias numbers and that's what I got.
Now you'll notice a couple things
here. One here, you'll notice what,
okay,
did he just truncated numbers?
He didn't round them off, right?
So it's always going to be low and
indeed it is low. His um, but that,
that's not low enough. Right?
What else do you notice
Angela?
He switched the numbers in the last row.
Okay.
He made an error. But the important thing
is he didn't notice. He made the error.
He added it up and sought. It
was 99.8 and thought, well,
what the heck?
It's 99.8.
It didn't because this was early days
of doing this kind of stuff. Okay.
Now, so we come over to doctor
prout is this experimental candor?
Well,
you find out if you add the numbers,
it's actually 99.94 or
five he added wrong.
Okay.
And now,
but those things really agreed right now.
You wonder how did old doctor prout do
this to measure it to one part in 5,000
right?
It turned out he measured the volume
of the gas and Hoodie reported was 6.3
cubic inches of gas.
Right?
So was he just lucky that it happened to
be right to force significant figures?
No,
because that's not how
he did the experiment.
What he reported was not
actually experimental.
He had a theory about atomic weights.
His theory was that everything
was made of hydrogen,
which isn't so far wrong
in terms of weight, right?
Because a proton and the neutron and
have the same way to Proton is hydrogen.
So everything is a sum of protons
and neutrons. Prac for weight.
The electrons are don't count
for much. Right? So it's
not actually such a bad, uh,
theory. So in his system, carbon was six,
oxygen, eight, nitrogen 14, you know,
that was what Integer, you
multiply them by. Incidentally,
hydrogen was called protitle from Proto,
let's say from Ila [inaudible],
which means the first substance.
Okay? So he had this theory.
So what he did was do a proximate
analysis, get about what the ratio is,
figure out what the ratio should
be in terms of small whole numbers,
and then multiplying by
his atomic weights. That's,
so these numbers are not
really experimental numbers.
They're more likely Lavoie Waze.
All right. So, uh,
so what he said was it was one, one to
one, and that gives those numbers. Okay.
So proud.
Did dry lab by making an
approximate analysis and
reporting results corrected by
his theory and so much for the paragon
of accuracy and honesty as far as we
would see it.
Okay.
But his theory was better than
parts alias as experiments.
That's interesting.
Okay,
so now ammonium sign it to Rio.
Let's review that from the point of
view of what we've been talking about.
So you have ammonium,
what makes it reacted?
Dana?
Hi Homo or low Lumo.
It's got a positive charge.
That's
one clue.
Anybody got an idea,
John?
And what?
What do you suppose that low little
bio is in terms of localized orbitals?
We're not going to talk about things
to go over the whole molecule.
There's not much to deal
with here at pneumonia.
You and you
can't hear very well
sigma star of Nh. Okay. So
that'll be a, that'll be the Lumo.
How about a homo on the other side?
There's a hint.
Okay. Unshared pair on nitrogen
with a negative charge. Okay,
so we've got these and we can do the,
the make and break trick attack
the Sigma Star with that.
Right?
So we've got back to ammonia
and cyanic acid, the uh,
possible starting place for getting there.
But if you have these two things,
you can react them with one another.
What makes ammonia reactive? Nh. Three.
High Homo. The unshared payer.
And how about the cyanic acid?
What do you see that it looks
like a functional group.
Don't worry too much about
how big it has to be.
Just see something that looks
familiar. C O Double Bond. Pi Star,
right. Okay. Now so we can,
so one of these can attack the other
and we could arrange them like that and
draw curved Arrow and we could
attack the co double bond.
But you could also attack
the CN double bond.
And in fact these aren't so different
because when you attack one and make an
unshared pair on the other,
in this case, for example,
that high homo on the nitrogen,
the end minus can be stabilized by mixing
with the Pi Star of the carbon eel.
Right?
So you could actually draw it either way.
So it really doesn't make any difference
which way you draw it at the beginning.
But what you can do is then have a
further reaction that the homeowner on the
bottom reacting with the sigma star.
Again,
although they probably can't
line up bright within a molecule,
it's probably one molecule attacking
another molecule to do this. Okay.
And get the hydrogen transfer.
And that is urea. Okay.
So there's how you go from ammonium
signed eight d urea. It's quite uneasy,
a chain of events.
You could have done it the other way too
like that and you'd get this compound.
But those molecules,
those molecules that the urea and this
one can lose a proton, go back on Louis,
go back on one side or the other.
And ultimately you get the
one that's more stable,
which is the one that has the
carbon oxygen double bond,
which is a very stable molecule,
a very stable grouping as we'll
learn later in terms of law.
You can actually understand it in
terms of Homo Lumo mixing here too.
But any rate, that's what
happened. So the question arises,
can ammonium cyanide exist
or does it always change?
Is there such assault or does it
always change to, to uh, urea.
And in fact it done.
It's our old pal and you're a great uncle.
Uh,
in 1998 with Kenneth Harris did an x ray
structure that showed that you can have
ammonium sign eight.
This was the first time that had
ever been proved to be to exist.
And there's what it,
what it looks like,
but notice the nitrogens on the ammonia
there point toward oxygen's not toward
nitrogens. So it's not, so you
couldn't, from this arrangement,
you couldn't have done that thing that we,
that we,
the mechanism that we drew in
order to get from here to there.
Okay.
So but that,
but the fact of getting
urea of product, of, of uh,
of animal metabolism from purely
as far as they were concerned,
inorganic things which is said to have
done away with the idea of vitalism was
not from my perspective,
the most important contribution here
because this is what Voltaire wrote toward
the end of that paper in 1828 I refrain
from all considerations which so
naturally suggest themselves from this
fact is that is that ammonium signed
eight and urea have the same analysis
especially in respect to the composition
ratios of organic substances and re
in respect to similar elemental and
quantitative compositions among compounds
with very different properties as
maybe supposed among others of
full Minnick acid and cyanic acid.
We already did those.
That was a problem early on when
we were drawing Lewis structures,
so two different arrangements at the same
atoms and have a liquid hydrocarbon in
the old defiant gas,
the Ola finance gas,
the gas that will make an oil is ethylene
and ch two ch two but that's very
similar to the,
that's exactly the same ratio of Adams
as you have in a long hydrocarbon.
If it has a double bond in it,
it must be left to further investigation
of many similar cases to decide what
general laws can be defined there from.
Now this,
this is an interesting point because
when people have certain tools available,
they tend to think that that's all
the tools that could be available and
therefore it gives all the
information that's possible, right?
So if what you can do
is elemental analysis,
you think that once you have
the ratio of the elements,
you know everything about the substance.
But what he shows here is that there can
be different substances that have the
same elemental analysis like
urea and ammonium cyanide.
So the possibility of saw Mariza's
showed there was more to be known.
Then people thought when all they
could do was elemental analysis.
So full Minuchin cyanic
acid was very important.
As we'll see in just a second.
Now puts alias wrote a paper just two
years later in 1830 on the composition of
tartaric acid.
Remember we,
we spoke before about how
pervasive tartaric acid is
in the 19th century and the
development of organic
chemistry and receive,
make acid also called John's
acid from the vose, uh,
on the atomic weight of lead oxide
together with general marks on substances
that have the same composition
but different properties.
So he found that tartaric acid and this
John's acid from the vogue also called
receive make acid,
had exactly the same analysis
their salts did right.
And here in fact, as a picture of it,
I have the actual stuff right here.
This is from a court,
from a wine bottle and on top of it here,
if we're lucky, see, uh,
you can see those. And
that's the, that we,
we took one of the crystals and put it on
the x Ray. There's what they look like.
They're beautiful little crystals and
their calcium. Tartrate. So I remember it.
You get a tartaric acid grows from
tartar on the walls of the wine barrels.
Okay. But this is what was
important, I thought at,
he wanted to give a name
for this phenomenon, things
that had the same analysis,
but we're clearly different.
I thought it necessarily to choose
between the words homo synthetic and ISO
Merrick.
The former is built from homos equivalent
and synth atos put together the latter
from Eso.
Mary's has the same meaning,
although it only properly says
put together from the same pieces.
The latter has the advantage with
respect to brevity and Ufuk [inaudible].
So it's shorter and it sounds
easier to say. So from now on,
we're going to choose isomers isomer to
talk about this phenomenon by isometrics
substances.
I understand those which possess the
same chemical composition and the same
atomic. By that he means molecular
weight, but different properties.
Okay,
so that's where isomers came from.
It showed there was more to be discovered.
There must be something about how these
pieces are put together that's different.
But how can you possibly find that out?
Just by doing reactions
in weighing things. Okay.
Same chemical composition, but
different properties. Okay?
So there's more to chemistry
than the analytical composition,
which is what they were good at measuring.
Now we know the importance of
atomic arrangement or structure.
So there are four cs that we'll
organize things about, composition,
constitution configuration
and con formation.
But you gotta be, patient does
take a little while to get there.
It was several more decades.
Okay? Now these, uh,
isomers of CNO have been calculated
to death in 2004 and we actually did a
problem, sat and showed these
earlier on. But here's what they are.
They're cyanic acid.
And notice this is the same anti in,
but you pulled the proton off
one end and put it on the other.
It's somewhat less stable, but
they interconvert easily. Okay?
There's the one, when you put nitrogen
in the middle, it's considerably higher.
That's called full Minnick acid.
And if you put the hydrogen
on the other end of that one.
Now the bottom one is what
volar we're working with,
but the top one was being studied by the
other Guy Liebig, the full Minnick acid.
And the name comes from Fullman,
which means lightning because I like so
many young lads leave big enjoyed things
that would blow up, right? He blew the
window out of the pharmacy where he was,
where he was serving as a,
as an apprentice, right?
And then he went to gay loose
sock to work on silver fulminate,
which is not great stuff to work on as
people who know from fulminate snow,
but any on 1824,
he was in Paris working on that.
And Galas sock noticed the paper from,
from Voler on the analysis of silver it
and saw that they had the same analysis.
So he, he got them
together. Gay Lusaka did.
Now know that when we're going to talk
much more about the interaction of those
two guys,
but notice in this portrait of leaving
that there is a device down in the bottom
right.
Remember,
people when they got their portraits made
always put something they thought was
significant there. So this is what he
thought was significant. And here it is.
Okay.
It's not the actual one. This is,
uh, uh, made by our glass blower.
Yeah.
And you've seen it before.
For example,
you come by this,
when you're hurrying to
class and notice right there,
same thing,
right?
Or if any of you are a student members
of the American Chemical Society that's
on the logo because that was the most
important device of the 19th century for
organic chemistry.
It's called the five bulb apparatus.
The food's Kugel opera.
Okay.
And it was used by liebig for analysis.
So here's how [inaudible] did
his analysis and you can see the,
the five bald apparatus here.
So,
so he had a too much like
Brett's aliases in which the,
he put burning charcoal in there to
heat it up and generate the gases,
but on a much smaller scale
than Brits alias did. Okay.
It came through a drying agent that
collected the water, that was a product,
and then it came into the,
this the fifth Kugel Operat,
uh, which was the co two collectors.
So in here with sodium hydroxide,
right. And what the way it worked was, it
was tilted a little bit. You notice that?
That it's,
that it's propped up here with some pieces
of wood so that the bottom isn't flat.
It's tilted like this.
Okay, so the gas comes in.
Yeah.
And because it's tilted, it bubbles
from one to the next. Right.
So mix as well and absorbed.
So you don't remember Lavoie Z.
I needed a couple of guys standing there
to stir those things so that the CEO
too, this was self collecting,
right? And then at the end,
you're cool. You're cool.
The thing I'm now notice,
what do you notice about the bulbs?
Here?
There are different size and
you had to put it this way,
not this way.
Why did you have to do it this way?
Okay.
Because what happened at the end?
You stop the fire and it would suck back.
So this had to be big enough to hold
all the liquid. This one didn't.
So they were different size.
You don't want to make both of them big
because you want to keep it as light as
possible.
It was made out of very thin glass.
So there's only one that still exists
that, that, uh, that Leiby cad.
And, uh, so it was tilted for the
reason we said, and here's the,
here's the original one,
which is still in, in, uh,
in Giesen in Germany where
he was a professor then. I,
but this was a great
advance because with this,
a single student could do three analyses
in a day rather than whether than,
uh, Lavoie Zia is big machine that
required for people working forever or,
or, but sale Ileus,
which required, you know,
waiting overnight for the co two
to be absorbed all and so on.
So this was the most important thing.
And everybody,
all the students who wanted to be organic
canvas went to learn how to do this in
Giessen. So liebig is every, almost
every one's great, great, great, great,
great. Whatever, grandfather in chemistry,
because all the people who went out to
teach studied how to do this with him in
Giessen.
So here's a portrait a little
bit later portrait of, of uh,
liebig after he had gone to Munich
to be a big wheel and, and uh,
but again, he chose in his portrait to
have a picture of the film of Kugel.
Operat. But if you look at it carefully,
you see something very interesting.
You see what it is.
As far as I know no one
ever noticed this before.
It's hooked up backwards.
How could he possibly have
hooked it up backwards?
He must told hundreds of students over
the years, look, when you put it together,
you put it this way,
not this way.
It's like which to buy the condenser
you connect to the water, right?
It's exactly the same kind of thing,
right?
So I just think that's amazing that he
did. He didn't notice that. But anyhow,
uh, there we got it backwards. Okay.
This was his teaching laboratory, which
still exists in Giessen. It's a museum.
It's interesting to go there and
there's a, uh, uh, on the wall,
there's this thing and it shows all of
his students and Grad students and great
grands students who became
distinguished professors.
And the ones in red are ones who got the
Nobel prize, the ones with red on them,
and you could,
you could extend it now.
It just stops in the middle of the 20th
century practically everyone's descended
from Lee. Be Concluding you. Okay,
this is his lab and here this is uh,
uh,
here's the orientee Gosa
from Mexico and he was,
he was supposed to be so good at analysis
that he could do better than leaving
did. Right. So he's the one that got to
hold the five co five bulb apparatus.
And what do you notice about it?
He's holding it upside down.
The potassium hydroxide would run out,
right?
And this guy is AWS Hoffman who there's a,
there's this thing of him is a master
in shining teacher of chemistry at
triumphant discover of
analysts and aniline dyes.
And he also was the guy that was
really good at languages and,
and devised a lot of the
names we use nowadays.
So we'll talk about that later
and hear in the background.
Looking through a window into the lab is,
it looks to me,
I'm not sure that that's what it is,
but it looks like a bust.
Is it look like a bus to you.
And if it's a bust,
it's probably this bust of Levy.
So there's,
it's fun to go there.
Okay.
So in 1832 leave,
Vic and volar collaborated to
develop the law, the radical theory,
and we'll just give an introduction to
that and not go all the way through it.
So leave, we can fully remember had
been introduced by Gailey's SOC.
So they were the same age and
doing similar kinds of things.
So they first met in Frankfurt at 1825
and five years later when they were
writing, they first used
the familiar, you know,
like two and in French or do in Germany.
If you're a really great friends with
someone, you know, within the family,
you use that. So they became
great pals and in 1832, uh,
volar said,
I longed to do some more significant work.
Shouldn't we try to shed some light on
the confusion about the oil of bitter
almonds. But where to get material. Right.
So you know, Baker, JT
Baker didn't exist then,
but if they were now they could just
order up a order up a bottle of it.
So C, can you smell this? Yeah,
you recognize the owner here. We'll
pass it around carefully. Don't drop it.
It's not that bad,
but you don't want to drop it and
see if you recognize the odor.
Like almonds is the oil of
better almonds. Good. Okay.
Okay.
So in June of 1832 just the next month,
liebig wrote to his pal volar and said,
my poor dear volar,
how empty is every comfort against such
a loss because his young wife had just
died. When I think how content
happy you were during your move,
what attachment and love you had
for one another. The good wife,
so young and full of life, so
irreplaceable for her parents and for you.
Come to us Derval are, although we
may not be able to give you a comfort,
we will perhaps be able to
help you bury your grief.
Stayed in castle at this time would
only be detrimental to your health.
We need to be busy with something.
I have just been able to get some of
Migdal and from Paris and I'm ordering 25
pounds of bitter almonds. You must
not travel. You must busy herself,
but not in castle. I haven't had the
courage to tell my wife yet. Come to us.
I expect you at the end of this week.
Know what he didn't want to tell her
about was the death of Fuller's wife
obviously.
Okay,
so then in July volar says it came,
the oil of bitter almonds has
come with the books from Paris.
I've kept half of it and I'm
here with sending you the rest.
I've already started all kinds of
experiments with it without being able to
obtain any precise results.
It seems to be a hard nut.
This is an example of
[inaudible] lame sense of humor.
He did this all the time.
I'm coming soon to you and we'll be able
to report so they work together for two
weeks on this and develop the most
important theory on basis of these
experiments. Volar returned. He said,
here I am again in my gloomy lonesomeness
not knowing how to thank you for all
the love with which you took
me in and kept me for so long.
How happy I was to work with you
from moment to moment here with,
I'm sending the paper on
oil of bitter almonds.
So next time we'll talk about what they
did with their oil and bitter almonds.